***
3 Jahre haben wir gewartet:
Die 4. Staffel
von "Stranger Things" ist da.
Teil 1 ist draußen.
Nur noch ein paar Mal schlafen,
bis Teil 2 erscheint.
Fakt ist jetzt schon:
Es gibt einen fiesen neuen Gegner.
Er beweist einmal mehr,
dass im Upside Down
alles miteinander verbunden ist.
Nur einer lässt sich schwer blicken,
nämlich der Mind Flayer.
Wir bringen heute
Licht in sein Dunkel.
Denn wir checken ...
Dustin, Trommelwirbel!
... ob so ein Hive Mind,
ein kollektives Bewusstsein,
auch bei uns existieren könnte,
wie das aussehen würde.
Und was das zu tun hat
mit Brain-to-Brain-Interfaces,
Vogelschwärmen und Schleimpilzen.
*Rock-Musik*
Tag zusammen.
*Telefon-Klingeln*
Hallo?
- Who is this?
Tag, Joyce, Jack Pot hier.
He's back.
Seit Staffel 1 haben wir es geahnt.
In der 2. wurde es bestätigt.
Im Upside Down
ist alles miteinander verbunden.
Es gibt dort einen Hive Mind.
Hive Mind?
- A consciousness, a super organism.
Ein Hive Mind ist eine Idee
aus der Science Fiction.
Verschiedene Individuen teilen sich
ein gemeinsames Bewusstsein.
Es gibt immer einen Part,
der die Kontrolle ergreift.
Der das "Gehirn" des Hive Minds ist.
Bei "Stranger Things"
ist das der Mind Flayer.
This is the thing
that controls everything.
It's the brain.
Er kontrolliert im Upside Down alles,
sogar die Ranken auf dem Boden.
Aber nicht nur dort.
Über Personen,
von denen er Besitz ergreift,
kann er mit der realen Welt
interagieren.
In der 2. Staffel ist das nur Will.
In der 3. Staffel
werden es immer mehr Menschen,
die genau das machen,
was der Mind Flayer möchte.
Da er eine Verbindung
zum Upside Down hält,
kann er von dort auch Waffen
in die reale Welt schicken.
Das sind fiese Kreaturen,
z.B. die Demodogs.
Oder in der neusten Staffel:
fliegende Demobats.
Welche Hive-Mind-Kreatur
findet ihr am fiesesten?
Ich nach wie vor den Demogorgon.
Wie ist das bei euch?
Schreibt es in die Kommentare.
Was kommt in der realen Welt
einem Hive Mind am nächsten?
Lasst uns das Wort anschauen.
"Hive" steht im Englischen
für "Bienenstock" oder "Schwarm".
Schwarmverhalten
kennen wir aus der Tierwelt.
Das gibt es bei Insekten,
Vögeln, Fischen.
Sogar Fledermäuse
fliegen in Schwärmen.
Aber im Unterschied zur Serie gibt es
bei Schwarmtieren kein "Brain".
So einen Mind Flayer,
der alle anderen kontrolliert.
Bei Schwarmtieren ist das anders.
Das sieht man am Beispiel von Vögeln.
Forscher haben Aufnahmen
von Staren-Schwärmen gemacht.
Dabei versucht ein Star immer,
zu den 7 Vögeln
in seiner nächsten Umgebung
die Position zu halten.
Er schaut auf die Vögel
in seiner Nähe.
Und versucht,
deren Flugbewegungen zu folgen.
Auch ist die Bewegung des Schwarms
immer zur Mitte hin ausgerichtet.
Wohl zur Sicherheit.
Denn wenn ein Raubvogel
den Schwarm angreifen will,
bietet ein dichter Schwarm
mehr Schutz für die Vögel.
Interessant für uns ist:
Jeder einzelne Star in einem Schwarm
hat jederzeit die Möglichkeit,
eine neue Bewegung zu initiieren,
der die anderen Vögel dann folgen.
Das sieht man gut
am "Gewaber" der Vögel in der Luft.
Wenn einer eine Bewegung initiiert,
folgen die anderen.
Dadurch wirkt das ganze "ziellos".
D.h., ein Vogelschwarm
ist eine Art Hive Mind.
Alle passen aufeinander auf.
Die Bewegung des einen
beeinflusst die anderen.
Das Ganze wirkt
wie ein einziger großer Organismus.
Aber es gibt
keinen "Mind Flayer"-Vogel,
der alle gleichzeitig steuern kann.
Jedes Individuum
kann den Schwarm selbst lenken.
Para, para, boom.
Vögel sind also nicht
der perfekte Vergleich
für den Mind Flayer.
Es gibt noch andere Schwarmtiere.
"Hive"
steht an 1. Stelle für "Bienenstock".
Schauen wir mal auf die Bienen.
Bei denen gibt es ja ein Tier,
das den Ton angibt: die Königin.
Makes total sense.
Es gibt einige Parallelen.
Zum einen ist die Bienenkönigin,
wie der Mind Flayer auch,
viel größer als ihre Arbeiterinnen.
Zum anderen kann sie die direkt
kontrollieren und beeinflussen.
Sie macht das chemisch
über Pheromone.
Mit Botenstoffen organisiert sie
den gesamten Bienenstock.
Das Problem ist:
Die Pheromone reichen nicht weit.
Daher ist die Königin
auf das kollektive Handeln
des gesamten Stocks angewiesen.
Die Arbeiterinnen
müssen die Pheromone reproduzieren.
Wie bei einer "Telefonkette"
wird die Nachricht weitergegeben.
Das ist schon "Hive Mind"-mäßig.
Die Ursprungsinformation
kommt nach wie vor von der Königin.
Sie ist weiterhin der Mind Flayer.
Der kann nicht nur
Informationen aussenden.
Sondern Individuen
tatsächlich steuern.
Über die Pheromone
unterdrückt die Königin
die Fruchtbarkeit der Arbeiterinnen.
Sie stellt sicher,
dass sie im gesamten Bienenstock
die einzige fruchtbare Biene bleibt.
Das ist für mich
total "Mind Flayer"-mäßig.
Bitchin, right?
- Yeah, bitchin.
Es gibt also Tiere,
die in Schwärmen leben
und als Einheit agieren.
Und manche leben in Schwärmen und
erhalten Anweisungen von der Königin.
Wenn das kein Hive Mind ist.
Lasst uns ins Detail gehen,
was den Mind Flayer ausmacht.
Denn das ist in der 2. Staffel
noch nicht so richtig klar.
Da wirkt er körperlos,
wie ein großes Gebilde aus Rauch.
Die Kids nennen ihn Schattenmonster.
Durch die Körperlosigkeit
hat er die Möglichkeit,
z.B. von Will Besitz zu ergreifen.
I don't think
it was anything at first.
I mean, I think
I just didn't want to believe it.
In Staffel 3
kann er sich manifestieren.
Also sich einen physischen Körper
zusammenbauen.
Das macht er
auf unappetitliche Art und Weise.
*Funk-Geräusch*
Does anyone copy?
This is a code red.
I repeat, a code red.
Er bringt erst Ratten
unter seine Kontrolle.
Er ruft sie zu sich
und baut sich aus ihnen
einen ekelhaften,
monströsen Körper zusammen.
Das macht er später noch mal,
dann aber mit Menschen.
Ihr denkt sicher:
Never gibt es so was
in der echten Welt.
Dass schleimige Substanzen
sich zusammenfinden,
um einen neuen Organismus zu machen.
Ich sage mal so:
1. sind wir "Science vs. Fiction".
Wir schauen so lange nach,
bis wir einen Weg gefunden haben.
Möge er noch so kurios sein.
Und 2. ist die Natur einfach
spektakulär eklig.
That's correct.
Es gibt keine Tiere,
die das machen.
Aber Schleim,
der da ziemlich nah rankommt.
Schleim-Pilze.
Technisch sind es keine Pilze,
sondern Einzeller,
die Eigenschaften von Tieren
und auch von Pilzen haben.
Da gibt es eine Art,
die nah an den Mind Flayer rankommt.
Diese hier.
Dictylostelium discoideum lebt
normalerweise als einzelne Zelle.
Aber wenn die Nahrung knapp ist,
schließen sich viele zu einem
multizellulären Organismus zusammen.
D.h., der Schleim-Pilz
rekrutiert keine Ratten.
Aber seine Artgenossen.
Und zwar folgendermaßen.
Wenn eine Zelle merkt,
es gibt nicht mehr
viele Bakterien zu fressen,
sendet die Zelle
ein hormonelles Signal aus.
Dann kommen andere Zellen auf sie zu.
Erst bilden sie
gemeinsam einen Haufen.
Er enthält bis zu 100.000 Zellen
und kann sich bewegen.
Es erinnert an eine Nacktschnecke.
Schleim-Pilz wird er genannt,
weil er wie ein Pilz
einen Fruchtkörper ausbildet.
Die Zellen
schließen sich also nicht nur
zu einem
multizellulären Organismus zusammen.
Sondern sie verändern sich dabei
und haben verschiedene Aufgaben.
Der Sockel, der Stiel
und der Fruchtkörper oben
sind 3 unterschiedliche Zellarten.
Auch wenn ich am Anfang gesagt habe,
dass das Ganze eklig ist,
finde ich es faszinierend,
was für verrückte Organismen
die Natur hervorbringt.
Es passt gut zum Mind Flayer.
Die Ausbildung
der verschiedenen Zellarten
sehen wir ja auch
bei "Stranger Things".
Denn der Zellhaufen dort
hat offensichtlich Zähne ausgebildet.
Eklig aussehen und fortbewegen,
das ist das Eine.
Aber das Gruselige am Mind Flayer
ist ja der Hive Mind.
Wenn ein Teil des Hive Minds weiß,
wo du bist, dann wissen es alle.
Das findet Mike
in der 2. Staffel schnell raus.
Will ist vom Mind Flayer besessen
und Mike checkt:
Mist, der kann dadurch
zum Spion werden.
We need to make Will sleep.
- What?
He is a spy,
if he knows where we are,
so does the shadow monster.
Die Kommunikation
an alle Teile des Hive Mind
passiert instant
wie ein permanenter Live-Stream.
Das gibt es in der Natur nicht.
Zumindest nicht
in der minimalen Zeit.
Erinnern wir uns an die Bienen
und die Pheromon-Telefonkette.
Da brauchen die Moleküle
eine gewisse Zeit,
bis sie sich über die Luft
übertragen haben.
Was wir bräuchten
für eine Instant-Kommunikation,
geht an die Technologie
des heutigen Internets ran.
Irgendwas
in Richtung Lichtgeschwindigkeit.
Da muss der Mensch nachhelfen.
Das passiert tatsächlich.
Es wird an einem
Brain-to-Brain-Interface geforscht.
Einer Schnittstelle
zwischen 2 Gehirnen.
Schon 2013 gab es ein Experiment
an der Washington University.
Da hat ein Mensch
einen anderen ferngesteuert.
Das klingt crazy,
aber es hat funktioniert.
Ihr kennt sicher ein EEG,
diese Haube voller Elektroden,
mit der wir Gehirn-Aktivitäten
messen können.
Weil wir die Ströme im Gehirn
aufzeichnen und auslesen können.
Das funktioniert auch andersrum.
Man kann das Gehirn mit
elektrischen Signalen stimulieren.
Im Experiment an
der Washington University wurde das
mit der transkraniellen
Magnetstimulation gemacht.
Sie haben eine Spule genommen,
über dem Kopf platziert.
Über das Magnetfeld der Spule
wurde ein elektrisches Signal
im Gehirn induziert.
Klingt einfach, aber
wir schauen uns das im Detail an.
*Telefon-Klingeln*
Hallo?
- Don't you dare!
We don't have time to talk about it.
Joyce, das ist kompliziert.
Das muss man detailgenau erklären.
Herrschaftszeiten.
2 Wissenschaftler
sitzen in verschiedenen Räumen.
Der 1. sitzt vor einem Bildschirm,
auf dem ein Computerspiel läuft.
Man muss immer dann
die Leertaste drücken,
wenn man schießen möchte.
Der hat aber keine Tastatur.
Die ist beim anderen Wissenschaftler
im 2. Raum.
Der 1. Wissenschaftler
soll nur daran denken,
die Tastatur zu drücken,
ohne es zu tun.
Die Gehirnaktivität
wird von Elektroden registriert
und an einen Computer geschickt.
Der gibt das Signal weiter
an einen 2. Computer in dem Raum,
wo der mit der Tastatur sitzt.
Er hat die Spule über seinem Kopf.
Die induziert
genau dieses elektrische Signal.
Damit löst sie
einen richtigen Tastatur-Druck aus.
Mega krass, oder?
Und auch total gruselig,
denn genau das macht der Mind Flayer.
Menschen beeinfluss
und gegen ihren Willen fernsteuern.
Ich kann euch beruhigen.
Denn es funktioniert nicht,
gegen den Willen zu arbeiten.
Hätte sich der 2. Wissenschaftler
aktiv dagegen entschieden,
die Taste zu drücken,
hätte ihn der 1.
nicht dazu bringen können.
In unserer Welt hätte der Mind Flayer
nur dann eine Chance,
wenn er sich eine EEG-Haube aufsetzt
und seine Demodogs und Demobats alle
eine Magnetspule über dem Kopf haben.
Und wenn die Internetverbindung
richtig gut und schnell funktioniert.
Also eher unrealistisch.
Vielleicht haben die noch einen
crazy biologischen Workaround dafür.
Aber das ist wohl
eher ausgeschlossen.
Fassen wir zusammen:
"Stranger Things"
wirkt auf den 1. Blick
strange, fantastisch, unrealistisch.
Aber schaut man genau hin,
sieht man überraschend viele Pendants
zu unserer realen Welt.
Wenn wir uns einen Mind Flayer
samt Hive Mind basteln wollen,
wäre es eine Kombi aus Vogelschwarm,
Bienenstock und Schleim-Pilz.
Und alle bräuchten eine EEG-Haube
und die Brain-to-Brain-Interfaces.
Easy peasy, right?
Wenn euch das auch so fasziniert,
lasst ein Like da,
abonniert den Kanal
und drückt die Glocke.
Dann können wir uns bald wiedersehen.
In einer Parallelwelt,
oder in dieser.
Bis bald, ich freue mich.
Ciao, ciao.
Dustin, wir können loslegen.
Shit.
♪ Turn around ...
♪ ... look at what you see.
♪ In her face ...
♪ ... the mirror of your dream.
You're a nerd.
Copyright MDR 2022